ce matin florence a rendez vous dans un
salon de coiffure au port florent
stecher a eu un cancer du sein en 2016
elle a subi l'ablation d'un sein et à la
suite de la chimiothérapie
elle a perdu ses cheveux
blue très bien en auriez il repousse
donc j'aurais voulu voir qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que tu proposes pour une
future beau principe c'est que les
cheveux mon repos c'est normalement
12h17 en sorte que d'ici trois mois
trois réunions mg petit coup florence
nous a juste demandé de ne pas la filmer
sans sa perruque moment là les petits
cheveux les premiers petits cheveux la
première étape ça va ça va s'épaissir
enfin de se densifier la perte des
cheveux c'est vrai moment difficile très
très difficile un matin où ben on passe
la main dans les cheveux etc
parties savaient qu'ils tendent
mais comment vous expliquez que ce soit
aussi important axe eu aussi difficile
cette étape là les cheveux pour une dame
je pense que c est déjà la culture donc
on quand on est petit en général d'ici à
la réunion les papas on touche pas le
fait de la petite fille et là tout d'un
coup il faut tout coupé on n'a pas le
choix c'est un signe extérieur de la
maladie parce que le cancer est une
maladie qu'il ne se voit pas mais un
moment ou à un autre mais on voit danser
c'est une même nous quand on se regarde
dans le miroir
mais on dit ben voilà l'heure n'est
malade donc ça vient de pousser avant
schéma là c'est bien parti je pense que
d'ici
oui on se revoit déjà dans un mois un
mois et demi je passerai la maison
saint-joseph et je dis bien très bien
quand on est content
[Musique]
l'après midi
nous retrouvons florence chez elle à
saint joseph
[Musique]
le moment vous avez appris la magie
c'est le monde qui s'écoule oui on pense
à tous et beaucoup de choses négatives
surtout on pense évidemment à la mort
évidemment et après on se dit bon on va
s'en sortir
deuxième étape annoncée à sa famille à
ses proches ma fille annoncé sa fille
lui faire comprendre que le cancer c'est
une maladie qui est g va mais qu'on peut
s'en sortir et je ne voulais pas qu'elle
qu'elle se dise que sa maman va mourir
essayez les moments de désespoir
oui
mais pas longtemps heureusement les
cicatrices qui
qui se referme difficilement se referme
toujours garder espoir
regardez fois
passez trouvé la force
des voix si murray là qu'elle est socio
esthéticienne c'est une amie d'enfance
victoire va bien ça va bien les deux
amis s'étaient perdus de vue
elles se sont retrouvées quand florence
a eu son cancer s'asseoir dessus
alors comment ça va bon écoute ça fait
longtemps que je pense at war et là il
faut il faut faire passer avec moi le
maquillage ça c'est pas du tout mon truc
mais là je crois que ça peut être un
plus pour black car avec la
chimiothérapie
florence a perdu non seulement ses
cheveux mais également ses sourcils mais
t'inquiète pas il ya des solutions je
vais te montrer comment faire pour
reconstituer vraiment en soit s'il de
masse de façon naturelle
ça te permettre de te 7e sur toute la
durée de la main quand il peut donc ça
va bien tu vois là haut niveau tout de
suite tu vois ça redonne 1 avait
carrément grave tu vois et ça tu peux
vraiment le faire toute seule comme une
grande
mais bon les bas mot avec maquillage ça
peut sembler futile mais c'est important
assez loin d'être futile pour la
restauration de l'image de soi que la
femme se sentent bien qu'elle garde sa
féminité qu'elle reprenne confiance en
elle et qu'elle puisse aussi bas à voir
tout le côté social du regard des gens
c'est une des choses difficiles
florence ne le regard le regard des
autres oui ça peut être difficile
surtout quand on regarde comme ça
comme est comme une animal étrange là
est ce que vous l'avez maudit de la
maladie traitée de tous les noms
non justement non ça jamais au contraire
j'ai toujours dit c'est un mal pour un
bien
un grand mal pour un petit bien
peut-être mais ça m'a fait recentrer sur
certaines choses ce qui nous tue pas
nous rend plus fort exactement
ah oui ça c'est vraiment con trats oui
quand même en graves
[Rires]
vous allez aller au sport moitié comme
jamais
florence a rendez-vous en bord de mer
avec son groupe de sport toutes les
femmes de l'équipe l'ont tué un cancer
du sein elles se retrouvent une fois par
semaine pour garder la forme mais
également pour des exercices plus
spécifique car à la suite de l'ablation
du sein
c'est tout le corps qui se retrouvent
déséquilibre on met les bras en croix et
on va monter les deux bras en même temps
important de travailler la symétrie
justement pour retrouver une symétrie
entre les deux bras les deux épaules
flo pourquoi vous avez eu envie de
témoigner aujourd'hui parce que à mon
tour j'ai voulu aider les autres pour
leur dire que le cancer existe le cancer
c'est dur mais on peut s'en sortir ou
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus aidé mon
moral
morales ma famille mes amis
ces personnes qui ont pensé à moi
qui ont prié pour moi qui m'ont soutenu
c'est beaucoup on a eu l'impression
pendant que cette journée que ça vous
fait du bien de faire ce reportage
ah oui carrément grade
oui parce que il ya des moments
difficiles
mais il ya tellement de moments
tellement de moments bien il faut il
faut il faut les prendre il faut les
il faut en profiter il faut il faut pas
rester tout seul